on débute ce journal avec le numérique à
l'école justement cet après midi la
direction académique des yvelines
présentait un bilan des différentes
actions menées sur le territoire et
présenter les nouveaux projets à venir
l'objectif c'est d'accélérer le
déploiement de cet outil
le reportage de nicolas kirillovitch
robot appareils photo table est le
numérique à l'école est devenue
incontournable dans les classes et
notamment dans celle des yvelines huit
mille ordinateurs 4500 tablette est plus
de deux mille tableaux numériques
interactifs équipe les écoles du
département d outil devenu indispensable
avec le temps je pense que pour leur
apprentissage c'est une source de
motivation pour apprendre à travers le
jeu et à travers des activités un peu
plus ludique que le manuel papier qui
toujours de rigueur mais qui qui je
pense doit cibler c'est aussi la place
au matin numérique et pour inciter les
équipes pédagogiques et les
collectivités à investir dans le
numérique à l'école la direction
académique de versailles lance de
nouveaux projets l'accent est porté sur
les robots un objet fascinant pour les
écoliers
autre nouveauté cette année civile en
yvelines pour raconter sa ville en
numérique il vilain divine c'est un
projet où les classes sont amenés à
présenter leur ville avec le numérique
présenté sa ville quand on est en petite
section de maternelle c'est peut-être
montrer les couleurs de sa ville
et puis à la fois quand on va être dans
une classe de cm1 ça va être de
travailler sur le passé lectra ce
l'histoire de la ville mais également
larchitecture la géométrie de la ville
pour découvrir le travail des élèves sur
l'ensemble du département y ville en
yvelines dispose d'un site internet